hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to towel required now as far
as I know this is a game about giving
naked people towels because they need
them
I don't really know otherwise hello okay
good
oh I got two oh hey how's it going
you're very naked excuse me sorry oh hey
okay alright little weird not sure why
or for your son hey kid
oh you're also naked Oh are they coming
toward all they're coming towards me
there's so we oh hey how's it going Oh
God
do not rub your body off on me what are
those golden towels it's so stupid
oh wow it is so stupid well they're
stuck over there oh my god where did you
all come from oh Jesus I'll get to you
in a second sir I am just one towel boy
my god this is so weird this is so weird
Oh get away get away get away I can't
jump god damn it oh crap
am I gonna die do I die if I lose
somehow I'm dead
I need to reevaluate landscaping service
- oh okay again again yes please yes
absolutely
now that I know what I'm dealing with oh
I'm just a poor innocent towel boy
trying to close all these very naked men
who are somehow murdering me and their
need half a toe maybe it's just that I'm
looking at them and I'm having a heart
attack because they're so attractive to
me we're like little old men zombies fat
old men zombies okay so the trick is not
to get trapped in one of the rooms oh
it's so stupid
at least the music is banging I'm so
glad they do have a tendency to get
stuck I'll have to report that to the
game developers because obviously it's
hindering like the performance no no no
no no no no no no no no damn it I I need
more towels I'm not doing if it's a
towel boy no no no bad touch bad touch
bad touch of the talib I will it's so
disturbing this getting to be more of
them oh there's so many of them I can't
handle all these what is it what did I
oh I made him stop in time that's handy
I don't know how what days did not work
for them not a pool boy have a towel boy
not a pool boy why would I be a pool boy
that's just weird stop everybody stop
I got him filled on it no I didn't so I
know where all the power ups now so I
can play this came to maximum skill I
can succeed and what I wanted to do why
do I want to succeed oh man in case it
wasn't obvious this came out of a game
jam and it was made in a short period of
time and I have like a permanent smile
stuck on my face I don't know if it's
just seeing all these lovely people walk
by or just because this game is really
simply an awesome in everybody this game
is amazing I love this is beautiful well
I mean it's not beautiful but it's uh
it's uh something it's a whole lot of
something she's Oh get away get away get
away get away
whoa that guy came a-runnin he wants his
towel real bad
I don't need double-speed I need towels
goddamn towels oh come on oh come on I
need towels not time oh I'm dead well
Wow okay I think I'm done I think I'm
done with this game the game is so silly
it's so silly but so awesome so anyway
this was towel required if you want to
play you can check out the link in the
description below try to beat my high
score why don't you it's something about
these silly little games that I love so
much oh god not that to you thank you
everybody so drowsy I'll get you outta
here Craig Lee and as always I'll see
you in the next video bye bye
all right
Oh God saggy old man underbelly lines
unless it's not as balls